If you're like most people, you probably use
butter on a fairly regular basis. Of course
there are plenty of great things you can do
with butter, but in this project, we're gonna
to be making it.
For this project I picked up a gallon of fresh
cows milk right from the cow. I let this jug
sit in the fridge overnight, and here you
can see a faint line where the cream has risen
to the top. Now if you don't have access to
a cow, you'll still be able to do this with
a heavy cream or whipping cream like this.
We need to separate the cream from the milk,
and it might seem a little counter-intuitive,
but the heaviest cream is on the top. We can
use something like a ladle to skim it off,
and transfer it to another container like
a wide mouth mason jar. Let's go ahead and
put the lid back on, making sure it's nice
and tight. And at this point, it's time to
churn the cream into butter, so start shaking.
..Now you're gonna have to shake it a lot,
and it only takes a few seconds to realize
this is going to be an amazing work out, but
if standing around shaking cream isn't your
thing, see if you can get a friend to do it
for you, or give it to your kids, and let
them work out some energy. You could even
take it with you on your morning jog. After
shaking your cream vigorously for about 3
minutes, you'll notice that it's transformed
into a light and fluffy whipped cream.
Now feel free to
take a 3 minute break. This will actually
make the process go a lot smoother, and you're
probably gonna need it. But when you get
back to shaking, shake that cream as violently
as you can. The harder and faster you shake,
the sooner you'll feel the cream break, and
when everything starts sloshing around in
the jar, you're done. This time when you look
inside, you'll see a big blob of, human powered,
homemade butter. The leftover liquid is traditional
buttermilk, and can be used for baking. My
wife used this buttermilk to make a batch
of these wholewheat buttermilk waffles. With
the buttermilk drained off, you should be
left with a beautiful ball, of golden yellow
butter. Let's compare the highest grade of
butter we found at the store, to the butter
we just made. Can you see a difference?
Now if you're like me, you'll probably want to
eat your butter right away, and that's ok,
but if you added a pinch of salt, it will
help it last longer and make it a little more
savory. I mixed in some local organic honey,
and a few other ingredients to make a delicious
honey butter, which, by the way, tastes incredible
on your buttermilk waffles. Well there are
a few ideas to support a healthier lifestyle
by shaking cream into butter. If you liked
this project, perhaps you'll like some of
my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com